Guten Morgen guten Morgen Tim.
Die haben doch gerade eins gemacht und ich bezeichne es als einen sehr großen Erfolg dass du jetzt abrisstest und,
das Metaebene Programm das Nuklearprogramm der Metaebene endlich ein Stammes und alles was ich machen musste war.
Nichts.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 258 die nukleare Explosion unter den Podcast.
Ja weil das Metrum falsch gemacht der einzige der nichts gemacht hat war ja kim-jong-un der macht nichts und Trampe hört auf mit diesen Übungen.
Was war noch mal.
Zwar noch mal machen leider.
Ja Mama nicht jetzt ist das so.
Jetzt habe ich zumindest bewiesen dass ist alles spontanes.
Es ist tatsächlich also spontan dass er noch nicht mal wissen wovon wir reden PSR.
Wie auch der Rest der Saison.
Prinz Prinz Donald Trump hat uns hat aufgehört mit den militärischen wird aufhören mit den militärischen Übungen mit sort Südkorea keine Sau wusste davon hat er sich spontan überlegt.
Und.
Für die Richtigkeit.
Ist auch geil sofort Alter wir stehen hier in Jahrzehnten wunderschöner Tradition eines vereinten Feindbildes auf einmal triffst du dich mit dem.
Also ich bin mir sicher was auch immer jetzt gerade der kurzfristige Effekt davon ist in zwei Wochen fliegt es allen Beteiligten um die Ohren.
Also dafür kann mir nicht vorstellen dass da irgendwas mit dem besten Stand haben dürfte erstmal wenn sie rausfinden dass er nicht viel passiert ist und dann na ja.
Die haben schönen Film gemacht.
Es ist schon wirklich es ist haarsträubend und wir uns ja auch immer wieder gesagt wirklich irre was was so.
Also die völlig irrsinnig dieses mit dieser Politik zu drohen wird und das nimmt ja in vielen Ländern zu.
Dieser dieses komische Video was er da irgendwie gemacht hat was wir was die Amerikaner dann noch mitgebracht haben im mit dem mit dem.
Bison Film Trailer Anne.
Ja genau ein Trailer wie werde jetzt hier,
das haben wahrscheinlich die gleichgemacht irgendwie die die die die Videos gemacht haben für Trumps betrügerische Neubauprojekte die Bewohner immer in der Wüste irgendeinen komischen Turm hinstellen wollte und alle investiert haben und er am Ende die da hat stehen lassen da irgendwie in,
oje also wirklich.
Das fehlte eigentlich nur noch so innerworld am Anfang.
In einer Welt die Beherrschung von einem völligen Idioten mehrere.
Kennedy selbst die bekloppteste Idee ist noch Früchte Bewerber bewirft.
Es gibt ein sehr despektierlichen Begriffe solche Menschen und das ist das psychiatrische psychiatrische Polytrauma.
Psychiatrische Polytrauma weil was wie also wer hat dass wir jetzt oder.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt die beiden ne aber also der eine ist ja ein Mörder und der andere ist ein Massenmörder.
Die also der Polytrauma ist wenn du halt eine eine Reihe an Verletzungen hast wo man es gar nicht mehr sagen also.
Unfall ne Polytrauma na das jetzt eine Reihe an Brüchen und.
Verlust und von anderen Leuten und alles.
Polytrauma des psychiatrischen Polytrauma ist halt nicht so unwissend störungs Suchbild ne also du hast das DSM IV vor dir und kannst einfach hier, das ist aber auch noch drin.
Störung Suchbild.
Na ja gut da können wir es nicht viel dran Regeln aber ich habe hier gerade auch ein Suchbild vor meinen nicht nur geistige Auge und ich bin ich erstmal er als entstörungs Suchbild,
bezeichnen.
Durch die großartige gesamtzeichnung von Roland von Logbuch Netzpolitik 256 du hast dich ja mit Thomas letzte Woche schon ein wenig.
Kurz über unseren Event ausgetauscht.
Ich hatte auch ein schlechtes Gewissen dass ich dir hier nicht die Gelegenheit gegeben habe also die wirst du dich natürlich ergreifen.
Erstens das zweitens naja war ja jetzt auch nicht falsch was du gesagt hast so.
Nur nicht vollständig.
Genau Alpha jetzt aber mal los natürlich ne andere Perspektive ist auch ganz interessant wieso Leute die halt nicht da waren das wahrgenommen haben von das ist natürlich nur ein einzelnes Beispiel war von einem.
Menschen der an der Situation eigentlich auch nichts falsches sagen darf.
Kannst du kannst sagen was wird bei mir kann jeder sagen was er will muss halt nur damit leben hat Konsequenzen hat.
Ja na ja was soll ich noch dazu sagen also ich fand es toll.
Bin einerseits immer wieder überrascht wenn wenn sich dann so Sachen würden so entfalten und man so die Leute kennenlernen fand es irgendwie auch schön dass wir Gelegenheit gab auch Leute kennenzulernen und auch im Nachgang.
Und verschiedene Leute angesprochen auch spät aber an Andy wenn es die ich traf die wohl.
Schönen Abend verbracht haben dazu.
Guck offenbar auch wieder unsere irakische Komponente bei so unsere pausenplanung war ja so etwas schwierig im Vorfeld im Nachgang muss ich sagen.
Darf ich dem gesamt Events sehr gut getan dass wir da diese zwei großen dicken fetten Pausen drin haben die so ein bisschen Hitze und verteilungs induziert waren aber die daneben allen auch die Gelegenheit haben.
Das Gespräch mit anderen Teilnehmern zu suchen und zu finden.
Und von daher finde ich hat der Event wunderbar dazu beigetragen dass ich da auch alle ein bisschen besser kennenlernen jetzt nicht nur da und wir unsere Wünsche huldigen.
Ja und denkt beim Vorprogramm haben wir auch ziemlich ein Knaller geliefert das war die richtige Idee wir waren ja am Anfang ja auch sehr am grübeln auch wieder so wie noch mal dasselbe in grün machen und.
Ja doch das war ganz gut dass du das nicht gemacht haben oder dass man sich eben was anderes einfallen lassen mit auch so jetzt habe ich keiner gerechnet hat war ein bisschen Arbeit an der Stelle auch von mir noch mal Dank an,
Henning OTTO und dann ist natürlich die da alle ihren Teil dazu beigetragen haben dass das so wunderbar geklappt hat.
Dann ansonsten ich war sehr zufrieden mit unserer Gäste Auswahl ich fand es dahingehend ausgewogen dass die Klimaanlage nicht so mitgespielt hat da können wir ja nichts für.
Akustisch muss man den Raum noch mal etwas besser erfassen da waren Logen Bereichs ein bisschen dünn.
Das ist schade dass das habe ich gerade erst von Dir erfahren das natürlich schade für die logischen Gäste nicht das perfekte Klangerlebnis hatten.
Also ja.
Das war nicht unsere Absicht.
Das war jetzt unser unser erstes Mal an dem Ort und dir das mal so ist und muss da erstmal.
Mal was ausprobieren und dann kann man auch ins Debugging gehen und nächste Mal Witz toller ja und nächstes Mal können wir durchaus vorstellen dass es das wieder geben wird.
Sprich denke klar wir streben eine Wiederholung dieser Veranstaltung an aber da muss natürlich auch erstmal wieder etwas Zeit ins Land gehen.
Also nicht Wiederholung sollte ich eine Weiterentwicklung ne weil ich das nicht dasselbe erzählen alles Konzept kam bei euch gut an ein zweites Mal und deswegen gibt es unsere relativ wenig Gründe das machen überhaupt hatten wir ne Menge Spaß mit,
Logbuch auf ja.
Und rot sozusagen der war ja neulich bei der GPN wir waren auch früher schon mal bei den Datenspuren Admin ich noch ein anderer Event wo wir auch schon mal waren.
Glaube das war.
Datenspuren waren wir.
Und wie du ja schon das mal angekündigt hast kann es auch durchaus sein dass wir in Wien auftauchen bei der privacy week.
Das sind natürlich dann mehr oder weniger in Anführungsstrichen nur normale Sendung also nicht wahr.
Das hat aber ganz gut wenn man sich so ein bisschen auch ins gemachte Nest da setzen kann und Bühne und Orga und Technik und sein an zu graben schon da ist und man sich da eigentlich nur noch hinsetzen muss und Sendungen machen kann.
Also man sieht ja so ein bisschen so unseren den den Drang,
Diesel oder DD den Spaß an der Sache solche Events auch wirklich halt vollständig durchzuziehen mit eigenem Design eigenem Sound Design von Florian Erlbeck dass es derjenige den ich vergessen habe zu danken.
Folglich ist immer vergisst immer ein.
Ja aber der kann ich ja nachher danken.
Ja von daher nicht so schlimm.
So Florian der uns sind noch in 8 bitte dass das den wie nennt man das der Intro das Intro gemacht hat.
Und auch das ganze halt in Partitur für Orgel.
Umgeschrieben hat was ja auch echt gut funktioniert hat also ich fand es toll sowieso.
Das Intro taugte offensichtlich in allen Varianten das kann man vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen aufbauen.
Ja genau und Einhorn Orchester.
Orchester wir brauchen ein Orchester.
Nein die DFB Einhörner das ist ein Fünfer sondergläser Trupp sein die LMP Einhörner und die spielen dann halt auf auf auf Horn.
Kann ja wohl nicht so schwer sein.
Das ist gar nicht so doof Einhörner als Horn Hörner da müssen wir uns mit der Jäger Zünfte wie gut stellenden.
Luder Kohlenpott hat schon sein Intro auf Horn gespielt.
Ernsthaft was das ja schon durch.
Ja ich weiß auch wer es eingespielt hat und ich weiß auch dass wir uns auch hört also denke hier keine Arbeitsauftrag entstanden.
Profi.de Einhörner.
Ja das kriegen wir das kriegt der Florian im Studio alles geklärt.
Genau Partitur für Einhörner.
Ja aber genauso diese das große Event das werden wir glaube ich nicht mehr als einmal im Jahr schaffen einfach weil das weil wir beide erfahren oder oder Spaß daran haben Events irgendwie wirklich auch.
Durch zu planen auf diesen.
Auf dieser Ebene mit eigenen Shirts Eigendesign eigenem Sound und Pipapo davon wird werden glaube ich in Zukunft.
Das auch weiterführen dass wir uns auf den CCC Events in den in den an dem CFP beteiligen das ist er dann deren Entscheidung ob sie das annehmen.
Muss jetzt auch nicht irgendwie dauernd machen aber es gibt ja jetzt noch irgendwie.
Also privacy Weg am Berge macht es gibt noch eine mrmcd da müssen wir schauen ob Tim da Zeit hat Datenspuren gibt's easterhegg gibt's gulaschprogrammiernacht gibt's immer gute Erfahrungen gemacht vielleicht.
Wenn es unsere Terminkalender erlauben und wir ohnehin und wäre wahrscheinlich ohnehin den Besuch der Veranstaltungen ja Plan dann werden wir uns ja gleich haben CFP beteiligen.
Genau was mir auch noch vorstellen könnte es es wird grundsätzlich vielleicht mal das Logbuch aber auch so on the road bringen jetzt unabhängig von gemachten Nestern da müsste man sich halt das Nest dann,
irgendwie machen das ist schwierig so.
Vielleicht wenn ihr Ideen habt welche Orte vielleicht.
Dafür.
Dann würde euch gerne mal melden also wir sind da doch so ein bisschen auf der gedanklichen suche und wissen auch nicht so richtig wie das Interesse da ist,
dann müssen wir natürlich ein bisschen Eintritt nehmen weil das dann eben mit Kosten verbunden ist aber dass wir sicherlich auch noch eine Option dass man sowas macht.
Mit weniger mit Eisfach halt mal live Podcast fertig ohne Schnörkel 1 eingang.
Genau vielleicht mit dem einen oder.
Anbietet oder nicht und.
Ein oder andere Schnörkel vielleicht aber halt jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht so eine fette Sause wie die Gala aber darauf läuft's dann halt immer hinaus in die Luft immer auf den Galadinner.
So wollen wir sein Reigen schlechter Nachrichten leicht mit der schlechten möglichsten beginnen oder blaue einen Todesfall zu vermelden.
Der Todesfall König der sich jetzt also das war schon länger klar dass dieser Todesfall irgendwann in näherer Zukunft auf uns,
zukommen würde nach schwerer Krankheit ist Meinhard Starostik gestorben,
Rechtsanwalt und Verfassungsrichter des Landes Berlin.
In unserer in unseren Kreisen deshalb bekannt ist weil er,
gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht gezogen ist ging die bestandsdatenauskunft gegenüber wieder Überwachung gegen Elena da viel zusammengearbeitet hat mit digital courage.
Dem Datenschützer Verein aus Bielefeld der Frühe FoeBuD ist also wovon zu fünften.
War da die Zusammenarbeit er hat da mit die,
die erste Instanziierung der Forza Einspeichung nämlich zu Fall gebracht also das war das Urteil was da an 2010 glaube ich gefällt wurde 2008 ging die,
Klageschrift ein das war dann,
331 Seiten Klageschrift und eine fünfstellige Anzahl an Vollmachten die in den Umzugskartons in Karlsruhe übergeben wurden 2010 dann das Urteil was die,
vor Datenspeicherung in dem in der ersten Ausprägungen eben auch in Deutschland zu Fall gebracht hat.
Und da war also sehr engagiert gewesen und es natürlich sehr sehr schade diesen.
Kämpfer für die Bürgerrechte so früh zu verlieren.
Du bist gerade word c3s hast du.
Ah ja oh ja.
Fischerwirt weil er war ja auch noch in anderen.
C3s Gründung Börse wo du hast recht für den für den Organizer gezogen hat die C3 die c3s Gründung damals mit begleitet.
Also das Projekt,
Teilschuld Commons collecting Society als diese GEMA Alternative die leider immer noch nicht da angekommen ist wo sie gerne sein möchten aber auch das sind sozusagen seine Aktivitäten gewesen da fehlt jetzt vielen Projekten glaube ich.
Der Input an der Stelle und wahrscheinlich der Output von ihm weil er war ja auch wieder auch fleißig und umtriebig und gar nicht aufzuhalten aber jetzt.
Hat ihm leider Krankheit das hat weggelegt.
Zur c3s haben wir die Logbuch Netzpolitik Folge 68 mit Dani Bruder auch noch mal verlinkt.
Ja ansonsten die schlechten Nachrichten so die üblichen.
Neues vom.
Hessen Trojaner gibt es wir haben ja bereits darüber berichtet dass CDU und Grüne,
in Hessen ein,
Änderungsantrag für das Verfassungsschutzgesetz vorantreiben und mit dem sie ursprünglich das Ziel hatten dem Verfassungsschutz Hessen auch das Recht einzuräumen Staatstrojaner,
zum Einsatz zu bringen kann es sich dabei um.
Also ohne Änderung an dem sogenannten hessischen Gesetz über die öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung.
Es wird sehr schöner deutscher Titel.
Jetzt haben sie sich das anders überlegt und haben gesagt naja pass auf nee wir dem dem Verfassungsschutz geben wir diesen Hessen Trojaner nicht.
Stattdessen wollen wir aber dann bitteschön das asog hessische Gesetze die öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung insofern ändern,
dass wir diesen Staatstrojaner jetzt der Polizei zur Verfügung stellen ja also und zwar im Rahmen der Online-Durchsuchung,
und der TKÜ wenn ich das hier.
Richtig sehr sehr schwierig zu verstehen wir müssen auf Seite 16 schauen und dort lesen wir auch dieser Gesetzestext ist wieder wie so ein.
Bis das heißt ist jetzt nach so und so wird folgender Satz geändert.
Kopierte Daten sind nach Stand der Technik gegen Veränderung unbefugte Löschung und unbefugte Kenntnisnahme zu schützen da geht's also in Richtung die Richtung Infiltration von informationstechnischen Systemen.
Für sowieso sowieso gilt entsprechend im Maßgabe dass das informationstechnische Systeme dass zur Datenerhebung Angriffen werden soll in der Anordnung möglichst genau zu bezeichnen ist ja und,
sie wollen dann eben mit dem Paragraphen 15C den verdeckten Eingriff in.
Informationstechnische Systeme Polizeibehörden können ohne Wissen der betroffenen Person mit technischen Mitteln,
in von der betroffenen Person genutzte informationstechnische Systeme eingreifen und aus ihnen Daten erheben wenn dies zur Abwehr einer dringende Gefahr für Leib leben oder Freiheit einer Person.
Oder für solche Güter der Allgemeinheit der ein Bedrohung die Grundlagen oder der Bestand des Bundes oder eines Landes oder die Grundlagen der Existenz der Menschen berührt unerlässlich ist.
Oder anders ausgedrückt wenn irgendwas ist.
In was ist ja unerläßlich ist ja glaube ich noch diese höhere.
Hürde aber der Satz geht dieser dieser Paragraph geht natürlich noch weiter es gibt da nämlich noch einen 15C sie können dies.
Lalala unerlässlich ist.
Darf ich nur gegen eine Person richten die gegen Paragraph die nach Paragraph in sechs oder sieben verantwortlich ist und nur in die von dieser Person genutzten Informationssysteme informationstechnischen Systemen eingreifen.
Soweit dann weiterhin wenn es zur Vermeidung von Terror und so weiter ne sehr lange sehr lange Beschriftung okay also Hessen Trojaner schwenkt oben auf Ermöglichung.
Von Trojan isierung und Online-Durchsuchungen für die Polizei.
Ja die Justizminister schwenken auch gerade um weil die haben sich auch gerade zusammengetan und fordern halt dass die Polizei jetzt auch in Wohnungen dafür einbrechen können soll,
damit diese Staatstrojaner auch mal installiert werden können weil sonst geht's mir ja irgendwie bei hat mir jetzt die ganzen tollen neuen digitalen Tools und kann sie überhaupt gar nicht richtig zum Einsatz bringen sie auch schade.
Oder Altersgeld für nicht so weil sie irgendwie remote nie reinkommen soll für einfacher den Leuten das direkt am Nachttisch irgendwie.
Ins Gerät zu operieren.
Das ist also wir halten das ja also wir halten es grundsätzlich für falsch.
Polizei diese Möglichkeiten zu geben weil entscheidende Fragen auch ungeklärt sind nämlich du sagtest gerade wie wollt ihr diese Infektionen denn anbringen ne es gibt auch eine.
Pressemitteilung des Chaos Computer Club dazu.
In dem indem wir die Fragen stellen so wer darf denn hier mal den Quellcode eures Trojaners einsehen um den zu kontrollierender was wie wird der Funktionsumfang und die Wahrung der Grundrechte,
Grundrechte durch diesen Trojaner kontrolliert wie gibt er in Wien justizielles,
Kontrollsystem wer programmiert den woher kommen die Sicherheitslücken die genutzt werden um den anzubringen sollen die wissentlich,
verfügbar gehalten werden mit anderen Worten nehmt ihr Schwachstellen auf unseren Systemen in Kauf und damit auf allen somit also,
Party zum Nachteil der Hersteller und deren Nutzer.
Wollt ihr im Schwachstellen dann kaufen und wie soll.
Ein verdächtigte nachher im Rahmen des Ermittlungsverfahrens kontrollieren.
Welche was genau diese Schatz auf der getan hat ja also man kann ja in so eine Schadsoftware Einsatz jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Stattfinden lassen und dann nachher sagen hier werden diesen beweisen wir haben diesen Beweis Sonne muss ja auch quasi entlastende Beweise genaue oder entlastende Informationen genauso zur Verfügung stellen ja das heißt du brauchst schon.
Eine nicht nur die gerichtsfeste Sicherung von beweisen sondern brauchst einen gerichtsfeste Sicherung des kompletten Prozesses.
Der da stattgefunden hat inklusive was was ich der Staatstrojaner in dieser Version wurde angebracht am durch.
Ein Zugriff erfolgte dann und dann ja so brauchst du vollständige Logfiles und so weiter um auch unter Umständen eben die Verletzung der Rechte des der verdächtigten Person.
Vor Gericht irgendwie wirksam vertreten zu können,
all das sind so Sachen über die sich hier keine Sorgen gemacht wird worüber die sich darüber natürlich Sorgen machen ist das wie kriegen wir diese Dinger angebracht und es ist natürlich so dass Computer heute durchaus.
In einen Zustand gebracht werden können der ist im Zweifelsfall.
Den Feld Wald und Wiesen Ermittlungsbehörden sehr schwer macht eine Infektion darauf anzubringen also wenn du.
Was weiß ich die gängigen also was ich für völlig normale rationale IP Sicherheit halte umsetzt dann wird das schon relativ schwierig den anzubringen zoom.in insbesondere aus der Ferne.
Und ich vermute.
Was passieren wird sind also dass sie sagen okay dann wollen wir eben einbrechen um unter Umständen auch sowas wie ein Hardware Trojaner anzubringen hier steht ja nirgendwo.
Dass der Trojaner eine.
Eine Software sein soll da gehen wir nur die ganze Zeit von A aus aber so den Text den ich gerade an den ich gerade vorgelesen habe da steht nicht muss ein Programm sein,
kein Eingriff in ein informationstechnisches System kann also genauso gut ein Hardware Objekt sein na ja wenn man Keylogger.
Sagen wir irgendeine Wanze wenn du von einem Telefon redest natürlich kannst du auch eine Hardware Wanze bauen.
Die.
Was weiß ich okay bei Messenger ist jetzt schwierig aber die was weiß ich dir im Telefon halte von mir aus die Gespräche mit aufzeichnet oder so.
Oder eben die die die tip.de die einfach nur guckt was du auf der Tastatur auf dem Display getippt hast oder so ne also denke ich jetzt nur mal so.
Er steht halt nirgendwo dass es ein Programm sein muss es wird genannt es ist ein Eingriff in ein informationstechnisches System so es gibt das eben auch in Hardware.
Und in in den Hof Sicherheitsbereichen ist das natürlich durchaus auch eben ein. Ne.
Also das machen die Hardware zum Abhören machen die länger als Software.
Bernasconi nur warum so kurz sozusagen mit welchen Leuten ist das zu tun haben grundsätzlich sollte man das ohnehin ablehnen weil es eben eine relativ schwerwiegender Grundrechtseingriff ist und weil.
Sie im Zweifelsfall nicht um die Sache herum kommen dafür Schwachstellen in irgendeiner Form offen zulassen die daneben.
Auch von anderen ausgenutzt werden können Sie träumen ja immer davon.
Dass sie irgendwann sowas wie einen exklusiven Zugriff bekommen ne also die in.
In den USA kennen wir die Debatten wo das FBI quasi versucht in diese Richtung zu gehen und sagt okay pass auf mach die Telefone zu finden wir gut.
Aber erlaubt uns macht für uns eine Backdoor.
Und man muss ja zumindest diese Überlegung auch einmal würdigen so das ist ja zunächst einmal.
Entkräftet ist das Argument dass sie Schwachstellen dafür nutzen welche zu welche das Risiko bergen auch von anderen ausgenutzt zu werden wenn der Staatstrojaner signiert von Apple auf dein Telefon geschoben wird.
Dann ist es eben so ja das heißt da keine Sicherheitslücken im herkömmlichen Sinne.
Wurden damit als Risiko für die allgemeine Bevölkerung verwendet muss man einfach mal sagen diese Option besteht apple wehrt sich aus guten Gründen dagegen.
Und das erkenne ich die die Argumentation nicht erkenne dich da sehr überzeugend finde ist von Christo gorean,
der früher sehr viel in der Öffentlichkeit aufgetreten ist als er noch bei der ACLU tätig war der aber jetzt für,
zumindest diese Legislaturperiode der USA.
Für einen also am Senat arbeitet als Mitarbeiter und dadurch jetzt deswegen hört man nicht mehr so viel von ihm.
Der sagt halt naja wenn.
Also im Prinzip müsste man sich die Hersteller in diesem Cyberwar ja so bisschen so vorstellen wie das Rote Kreuz im im Krieg.
Ja es gibt einfach bestimmte ganz klar neutrale vertrauenswürdigen Instanzen.
Denen du immer vertrauen kannst wenn du jetzt als ist egal ob du nordkoreanischer Soldat oder oder US-amerikanischer Soldat bist.
Den Sanitätern die kümmern sich um dich und die sind neutral in jeder Hinsicht immer.
Und eine ähnliche Rolle in einer ähnlichen Rolle sieht er eben die Hersteller von Produkten das klingt jetzt sehr,
hoch gegriffen als Vergleich aber ich denke schon dass ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt ist das ist auch im Interesse der Hersteller von Geräten und Software ist,
dass sie nicht von sich reden machen als die gewähren ihrer Regierung oder den Geheimdienst oder sonst jemandem willentlich.
Zugriff auf diese Geräte und der GE der Grund warum ich das so sehe.
Ist die wollen doch im Zweifelsfall solange der solange Trump noch so ein bisschen restlichen internationalen Handel gestattet auf diesem Planeten ja unter Umständen auch ihre Produkte ins Ausland verkaufen.
Und ich frage mich ernsthaft also was machst du ja was du hast es ist genau die Diskussion die Apple und Google die ganze Zeit führen,
das dann nämlich China sagt achso,
ja nee wollen wir auch hier iPhone alles cool und so aber hier übrigens eure klaut ne die kommt mal schön bei uns.
Hinter die Mauer und ihr kennt ja unsere Regeln wie wir das hier so sehen wir Zugriff achso wollt ihr euch nicht dran halten ciao.
Dann sehen wir ehrlich gesagt nicht hier dass ihr verkaufen wollt,
und wenn das jetzt auf einmal jeder Staat dieser Erde macht dann hast du genau wieder diesen Dammbruch das dass du das sagst ja gilt als selbstverständlich muss äppeln evektor für für den.
Für das LKA oder für die für die Polizeidienststelle.
Kreuzberg 61 bereitstellen aber wir werden wo kommen wir denn hin wenn deutsche Bürger auf einmal im Ausland nicht mehr sich sicher sein können.
Dass sie da nicht von weißt du was weiß ich irgendwelchen südkoreanischen oder chinesischen oder nordkoreanischen oder Gott bewahre russischen.
Behörden ihr Vene zugekommen und deswegen glaube ich halt dass die.
Die eins der einzige sinnvolle Umgang mit informationstechnischen Systemen ist dafür zu sorgen dass sie sicher sind.
Dass man diese Sicherheit konsequent ausbaut und dass alle in den Genuss dieser Sicherheit gebracht werden.
Ich kann ja so die Deutschen immer so ein bisschen verstehen ne wir haben ja hier so dieses,
Bild von naja es mag ja nicht alles kaputt nicht alles in Ordnung sein aber grundsätzlich leben wir ja hier in einem,
Garten der persönlichen Freiheiten und des Rechtsstaats und behaupten unsere freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung und so weiter wisst ihr alle Fans.
Ja den würde ich sogar weitgehend zustimmen insbesondere im internationalen Vergleich schneiden wir da nicht schlecht ab.
Und die ganze Debatte aus unserer Richtung heraus.
Heißt auch gar nicht mal so sehr dass wir jetzt zwangsläufig immer der Meinung sind dass die Polizei oder die auch die Geheimdienste grundsätzlich jetzt schon so böse sind wobei bei den Geheimdiensten würde ich das,
Zipper Frank wollen.
Siehe auch Logbuch eines für die 256 unser Gespräch mit Martina Renner er das noch nicht gehört hat sollte das auf jeden Fall als erstes werden weil.
Das fand ich uns vom Geistrohr geredet auf fertig kann ich super super cool von ihr wie sie sich da präsentiert hat ganz egal.
Das Ding ist nur man muss ja nur mal die sind AFD waren ein bisschen weiter denken oder halt auch mal nach Ungarn oder sonst wo schauen und bei uns reicht ein Blick in die Vergangenheit.
Wir sind nicht so unangreifbar in unserer Situation wie wir vielleicht immer glauben andere Staaten sind da schon viel mehr gestrauchelt.
Wir sehen das auch Verbündete schnell mal abdriften können siehe,
den merkwürdigen Pfad in die USA jetzt gerade einschlagen und wie wenig auch das Establishment dann dagegen tut das bin ich ja ehrlich gesagt noch am meisten verstörend also dass der Typ irgendwie Panne ist ok aber,
wie sehr die sich da alle irgendwie auf rein und wie das Lied mitsingen der OC essen.
Das ist wirklich beunruhigend und so eine Situation können wir hier auch haben falls nicht ich sehe das kommen und das wird morgen soweit sein aber es geht halt.
Und die Polizei und die Behörden unser Staat muss auch immer wieder verstehen.
Diese tolle Grundordnung vor allem davon geprägt ist dass der Bürger gegenüber dem Staat geschützt werden soll wir reden hier von Schutzrechten des Bürgers.
Und mit dieser ganzen ganzen Mantra mit ja und hier die bösen Terroristen und bösen Islamisten und,
wer auch immer gerade wieder der der böse dujour ist weil das ändert sich ja nun hatte Dich auch ja also jetzt ist gerade mal Islam und Terror,
ich prophezeie in 20 Jahren,
vielleicht auch schon den 10. schon fünf Jahren diese ganze Debatte schon wieder hinten übergekippt und wir reden über irgendwelche anderen Bedrohlichkeit and.
Oder diskutiert halt durch mit denen die wir schon hatten ne der Maya.
So und dann dann sind halt einfach andere Bedrohungsszenarien die immer wieder dieses ach Gott wir sind doch eigentlich die guten wir wollen euch doch nur beschützen etc der war aber einfach komplett übersehen.
Dass dieser Staat eben auch schnell mal abhanden kommen kann und dass wir gerade in dem Moment wo so Trappisten anstarrt kommen und solche Leute haben wir natürlich ja auch.
Dass die sehr schnell mit mit mit viel Gespür.
All die ganzen Wege finden wie sie ihre eigene Macht stärken können und die scheißen dann auf Konvention,
die scheißen dann auf irgendwelche Regeln wie das immer schon so gelaufen ist und was der Anstand gebietet RCA das kann man beim Trump wunderbar sehen ja der segelt jetzt an einem vorbei wo immer alle gesagt haben da ja aber so haben wir das ja noch nie gemacht und er sagt mir egal.
Scheiß drauf ja alles wo ihr mir nicht sofort ne Kanone in Rücken halten könntest wegen mache ich jetzt einfach mal.
Und auch die Praxis in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und auch unsere Nachbarn nennen ist auch viel davon geprägt was so Konvention ist,
wie man die Medien besetzt,
ecetera ja also stehen meine AFD in Regierungsverantwortung vor die wir immer so schnell bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen drin und am Start und würde schon mal die ersten Wege für die Übernahme des Medien Diskurses,
bei Unternehmen und da haben wir unter Garantie nicht die richtigen Regularien um das zu verhindern.
Wie ruckzuck die AFD auf einmal ihre Liebe für die Menschenwürde wiederentdecken würde wenn ihr gauland da einmal im Badehose zurück marschieren muss ne hast das mitbekommen.
In other news verweigert Italien die Aufnahme von 600 in Seenot geratenen Personen in ihrem Hafen,
und wir diskutieren über die Menschenwürde von so einem Deppen der irgendwie den beim Baden die Hose gezockt wurde ne.
Ja und in die Menschenwürde in zweifacher scheißegal.
Könnt ihr denn unterstützen,
wär ja dann irgendwie diese Springer Springer Verlag hat auf einmal den kurzen Moment in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik wo der Springer-Verlag sich auf einmal für die Würde eines Menschen interessiert hat ja er war ja dann irgendwie haben sich ja dann gepostet also wir aus Menschenwürde Betrag,
drucken wir dieses Bild nicht ab,
meine Güte ey die jeden Tag ne nackte Frau da drauf und wenn da bloß mal irgendjemanden der Nippel aus dem Hemd guckt haben die das auf auf auf A0 da drauf ne.
Meine Güte ey ok.de anderes Thema.
Gerne anderes Thema aber Symptome der ganzen Verlogenheit so und vor dir nur darauf hinaus das ist der Grund warum man eben diese permanenten Verschärfung und diese permanenten übertreib.
Der Status Quo einfach weiterhin sehr sehr sehr kritisch und in gewisser Hinsicht eben auch direkt entgegengestellt sein sollte,
weil die ganze Argumentation warum man das unbedingt braucht jetzt haben wir bisher letzten 30 Jahren immer schon gesehen fällt irgendwo zusammen,
die Dinger sind nicht effizient das bringt alles nix normale Polizeiarbeit die man um die auch billiger haben kann bringt vielmehr,
ja das ist einfach immer eine Frage der Prioritäten.
Untere wir hatten sie gerade schön hier auch in Berlin wieder so naja die Polizei konnte ja diesen Terrorverdächtigen alles andere nicht weiter beobachten ja war,
warum weil irgendwie der Innenminister der Meinung war beim bist du jetzt mal die ganzen Truppen Erreger,
zusammenschieben um da irgendwie ein besetztes Haus sogar wach weil es ja viel viel viel wichtiger was dafür eine unfassbare Bedrohung ausgeht von so einem Haus ja.
Und was das Problem dort jetzt haben wir für dieses kurze Thema schon wieder sehr viel Zeit aufgewendet aber das muss ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Ernesty International.
Daran anschließend wir räumen ja so ein bisschen auf wir haben ja die Logbuch nicht fertig 256 Pause im hat jetzt zu einem gewissen Themen Stau geführt,
Amnesty International hat eine längeren Report veröffentlicht an dem,
da seit einigen Monaten gearbeitet wurde sie mir wie ich erfahren habe.
Und da geht also wieder um Menschenrechtsverteidiger Rennen und Menschenrechtsverteidiger in Pakistan dieses Mal,
die sehr gezielt von Angreifern mit falschen online-ident von angreifenden mit falschen online Identitäten über Social Media.
Kontakte angesprochen wurden nasil wieso wir interessieren uns hierfür Ihre Menschenrechts,
LTE Menschenrechts Engagement ich habe hier einen Fall so da ich bin ein Journalist ich wurde verfolgt oder sowas und den hat irgendwelche infizierten PDF-Dateien untergeschoben ja,
und das ist also hierfür für mehrere Personen der Fall gewesen die dann weil ihm das irgendwie komisch vorkam.
Diese diese Dateien die in der zugeschickt wurden an MSC gegeben haben MSC hat ja vor einiger Zeit schon mit diesen Diddl forensic style.
Die ein oder andere sehr kluge Personen angestellt die sich um solche Dinge kümmern Nase die dann diese Trojaner und Malware Angriffe auf Menschenrechtler analysieren.
Bemerkenswertes Upgrade der Häuser Zion für dich also auch vor wenigen Jahren noch nicht so gut denkbar.
Na Siam heute einen der besten Leute dafür ne also Claudio gone ieri ist viele Jahre in dem Bereich bekannt früher mit dem citizenlab also unter Ronald Deibert die Gruppe in.
Jetzt wahrscheinlich Toronto ne die wo die wo die sitzen.
Also citizenlab die Gruppe da hat er ja schon irgendwie Trojaner Forschungen betrieben statt zuhören Erforschung getrieben und das ist jetzt auch hier wieder eine Arbeit von von Claudio.
Und der ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren oder so Wisch! Ja also da sehen wir es ne das,
gibt's fertig dann auch wieder diese diese Berichterstattung in diesen Ländern ist natürlich so ein bisschen.
Schwieriger na das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so als also wenn du als Paket pakistanischer Menschenrechtler Saphir ich habe,
Staatstrojaner Angriffe und so bekommen dann musst geht es eher darum dass diese Leute überhaupt leben auf dem Land kommen ne also musste ja irgendwie teilweise daneben evakuieren na dann reden wir halt wirklich von der etwas anderen,
Arbeit als wenn jetzt mal in Deutschland hier man Journalist wegen Landesverrat ein Ermittlungsverfahren kriegt oder so eine Sonne da hast du halt ruck zuck ganz ganz andere.
Situation nämlich auch dass Menschen einfach verschwinden.
Und naja in diesem Bereich gibt es also jetzt hier diese Ergebnisse von Amnesty die dann auch noch ein bisschen.
Darüber Auskunft geben wie denn was ist denn da für eine Schatz auf der ist wozu die wiederum Ähnlichkeiten aufweist und der warum man dann davon ausgehen kann dass dort eben in Zusammenhänge zu den.
Dienstleistern bestehen die irgendwie für Militär oder Geheimdienste oder Polizei eben auch solche solche Tools bereitstellen.
Tasse Geschichte kann man sich auf jeden Fall mal mal anschauen und da ist natürlich dann sofort irgendwie wiederholen mein Gott parkistan das ist aber böse na aber das ist ja krass was die was die Pakistanis da machen und in Wirklichkeit sind wir.
Ganz und gar nicht weit weg davon solche Situationen in Deutschland eben auch einzuführen.
Dann kann sich ja jeder ganz gut vorstellen dass schon mal vor man würde sich jetzt hier für ein umstrittenes Projekt was,
zudem startet jetzt gar nicht so passt oder auch anderen Gruppen engagieren und würde das auch fleißig kommunizieren dass man das tut was für uns ja vollkommen normal ist und dann kriegt man halt so ein,
Geheimtipp mit hier guck mal hingelegt Dokumente,
da klickst du drauf so hat er denkst du gar nicht groß drüber nach und schon schwupps hast du dir halt Software eingetreten.
Also ohne lange da also das öfter mal so Dokumente aus komischer Quelle oder gesagt wird Linus kannst du mal kannst du das mal aufmachen.
Ja klar dass das Risiko besteht natürlich grinsen oder crimes on oder so heißt,
diese grinsen als diese diese Chartsoftware mit sms die Haut ja dann die gesagt das sind eben keine Lumpen,
76 seitigen Bericht ne mit technischer Analyse und die Briefe da drinnen und was ist für die Deutsch für die Menschen bedeutet über welchen Messenger die das Folgen welchem linkedin-profil geschickt bekommen haben und so die machen das halt.
Und ich.
Aber zur EU geht's auch weiterhin ähnlichen Bereich der Zeit ist.
Sind mir weniger Berichterstattung von politischer Planung der Zeit bei der EU um die sogar sie Evidenz richtiges hat mir ja auch schon mal erwähnt ne.
Wann wir noch mal kurz beleuchten weiter vorangeht im Kern will die österreichische Ratspräsidentschaft noch bis Jahresende da eine.
Ein Ergebnis erzielen verwundert jetzt gar nicht dass unsere neue stramm Rechte Regierung aus Österreich hier hinterher ist,
worum geht's jetzt richtig verstanden habe Evidenz ist halt quasi oder sagt dir der Name schon so ein bisschen Beweissicherung,
was heißt man möchte hier gerne Mittel schaffen um eben Beweise auch in digitalien zu erlangen und dazu plant man seine,
big freeze ähnliche Vorgehensweise cricfree Federn und ist so eine der diskutierten.
Nicht nur das.
Also es geht ihnen ich will nur ganz kurz sagen Sie es geht bei diesem Europarecht in die wollen ja immer etwas harmonisieren Ja und in diesem Fall eben eine,
da geht es um die Regulation der europäischen Produktion und präservation von elektronischen Beweismitteln in,
kriminellen Strafverfahren und auch noch eine Direktive die die Regeln harmonisieren solvi.
Legale Repräsentant.
Amanda's auf Deutsch also wie man quasi welche wie man durch welche Instanzen diese Beweismittel in kriminellen Ermittlungen,
ermittelt werden sollen also es geht da.
Einerseits um einheitliche Gesetze in diesem Bereich und andererseits darum das natürlich auch dann die Zusammenarbeit und so weiter Gestalt gestärkt werden soll.
Das betrifft dann halt eben die Telekommunikation auch wieder weil hier dann quasi auf Zuruf und deswegen ist das jetzt mal als Quick freeze bezeichnet weil das ist ja quasi so diese Variante mit naja Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist wir speichern immer alles,
ja und der Zugriff erfolgt quasi autonomen vom von der von dem von den Behörden ja.
Oder dass die Anbieter davon groß was wissen oder musst du arbeiten müssen und quick freeze ist mal so dieses naja wir teilen euch mal mit das jetzt ab hier so eine Beobachtung stattfindet die habt ihr jetzt mal zu ermöglichen und,
Buddy auf zu oft wird daneben ab dem Zeitpunkt wo dieser Zuruf erfolgt ist mitgeschrieben und dann kann das eben zur Beweissicherung,
gemach.
Was ihn was ihn daran nicht gefällt ist sie hätten gerne den realtime intercept of data ja,
also quasi sie möchten auch das haben oder das wird gefordert und dann nehmen Sie den US Cloud act als primär Beispiel ja das wollen Sie also im Prinzip genauso haben also sie wollen.
Echtzeit intercept von Daten.
Und dann wollen sie außerdem noch direkten Zugriff auf E evidence wo sie sagen das wäre super toll und bedeutet halt auch irgendwie so eine.
Quasi den mit wie EU-Mitgliedstaaten ermöglichen aus der Ferne die auf die Daten zuzugreifen die nach einer search search and feature of the device.
Erlangt wurden also es wurde ein Gerät.
Durchsuchungen zu sich.
Such der sichergestellt ich such da waren sie direkt in gesund schön.
Zugriff darauf haben das haben halt auch die wollen halt gerade mal wieder aus dem.
Sind fallen aus dem Vollen schöpfen.
Bestand Verkehrs und Inhaltsdaten für interpersonelle Kommunikationsdienste einmal alles innerhalb von einer Stunde Zugriff.
Da ist dann alles alles drin nein irgendwie Personendaten Pipapo Wasser haben hinguckt Nummern von SIM Karten Passwörter Verkehrsdaten kaufhistorie.
Naja.
Jeder jeder Art von Straftaten soll also die Herausgabe von Teilnehmern Zugangsdaten ermöglichen also nicht irgendwie Beschränkung auf Terror oder sowas.
Transaktions und Inhaltsdaten nur bei Straftaten ab einer Freiheitsstrafe von mindestens drei Jahren.
Tja das ist schon echt.
Mach dich auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mal Gedanken darüber was ihr überhaupt irgendwo hinterlassen wollt das Esszimmer,
die beste Methode die Datensparsamkeit ausfüllt mich weiß es nicht immer die Möglichkeit und manchmal ist es auch einfach viel zu praktisch alles online und digital zu machen aber,
Mathis Kalender doch irgendwann mal auf die Füße fallen aber davon,
gesehen das war aber diesen Prozess begleiten und deswegen melden wir das jetzt hier ne also evident ist jetzt ein Thema abgesehen von dem was jetzt der letzte Woche hier schon besprochen habt Copyright Regelung erzählt dass hier noch schlimmstes verhindert wird,
aber das nächste Thema ist natürlich schon auf der Liste.
Ja aber wo kann er denn diesen zusammen mal kurz dazu raten also alte Geräte immer also zu kaufen alte Laptops und so die man noch mit,
mit halbwegs brauchbaren Betriebssystem betreiben kann empfiehlt sich sehr 40 unter Umständen die Investitionen in VPN-Dienste wenn man schnell im Internet unterwegs sein kantrohr.
Browser bereitzuhalten und ein anonymes E-Mail Konto auf dass man nur über trotz vergreift das gehört einfach zwischen leider zur Grundausstattung.
Tessa.
Digital Dasein ist besonders wenn man sich jetzt in sensitiven Umgebungen.
Ja ihr also diese die.
Wärt ihr ebenso ein bisschen langsam über ein paar Jahre so in the cloud vereint habt und am Ende noch nicht mal mehr wisst wir den wir den Mister überhaupt rauskriegen sollt geschweige denn welcher Mister überhaupt drin ist wie bei Apple,
wie ich hier die letzten E-Mail-Empfänger die sie in die iCloud schieben hat das mitbekommen ja damit,
zur Vereinfachung damit sie schneller Verein auf deinen Geräten die e-mails verfolgt.
Vervollständigen können schreiben sie halt die letzten Leute an die du E-Mails geschrieben hast in dieser iCloud und gebe dir noch nicht mal ne Möglichkeit das zu löschen ne also also das ist wirklich ein ein ein Sumpf,
indem man da ein Treibsand indem man da Geraet und da sind unten jetzt wenn jetzt langsam natürlich auch die Schlangen reingelassen in den Treibsand.
Ja in einem anderen Treibsand fand sich Google wieder,
nachdem sie ihre ganzen artificial intelligence machine learning Projekte varia vorangetrieben haben und das hat auch immer noch tun.
Haben sie auch an verschiedenen Bereichen sich so zunehmend auch in militärischer Operationen angenähert.
Man kennt das ja hier auch der Aufkauf von dieser Roboter Bude hier sind auch gleich.
Andy die die immer diese diese gar nicht gibt diese Klasse die Haltedauer.
Ich komme gerade nicht drauf.
Hier wird mit Robotics ne.
Boston Dynamics.
Boston Boston Boston Dynamics genau.
Hans aber doch jetzt wieder abgestoßen und so egal wie auch immer auf jeden Fall haben Sie das schon immer bisschen geliebäugelt mit diesem doch sehr ertragreichen Bereich der Wirtschaft unten.
Das wurde dann vielleicht so ein bisschen auch untergraben das ja eigentlich in ihrem offiziellen Firmenmotto drin stand dass sie ja nicht übel sein sollen das haben sie ja nun vor ein paar Wochen dann auch gestrichen.
Das ist krass oder.
Er weiß aber auch nicht stimmt also.
Der Kater trotzdem drin lassen.
Das war alles war schon wirklich lächerlich.
Ja aber das dann auch also das kann man ja ich mein.
Also ich finds halt in gewisser Hinsicht ehrlich.
Du bei jedem Fußballspiel singen die oder welchem Fußballspiel mit Jogi Löw singen Siegen von einigkeit und Recht und Freiheit in bestimmte Traditionen behält man halt einfach bei.
Wieso bist du nicht mehr einig.
Aber bestimmte Sachen sind natürlich das lächerlich einfach lächerlich Wände Wände bin.
Egal auf jeden Fall Google.
Politiker unter anderem gab's das project Maven und das ist jetzt insofern interessant als das ist halt einerseits mit dem drohnenprogramm des Pentagons zu tun hat,
und natürlich dann auch gerade Googles Erfahrungen im Bereich er da sehr gern gesehen sind,
wird ja aber muss um sozial und mit dem Pentagon zusammenarbeiten zu können muss man so verschiedene clearances ableisten damit man dann überhaupt auf diese Daten zu kommen also angenommen Sie würden jetzt tatsächlich militärische Drohnen,
diese Trainingsprogramme reingehen aber wir erinnern uns so,
Marrons kriegen was jetzt ja eigentlich das Objekt ist es hat sich so eine klassische machine learning Aufgabe in gewisser Hinsicht so viel Daten die permanent beobachtet werden mussten das Ding kreist über Feindes Gebiet und muss irgendwie herausfinden was denn jetzt,
wirklich verdächtig ist.
Dazu muss natürlich diese ganzen Videodaten auch erstmal haben um darauf um trainieren zu können und auch allein dafür brauchst du schon so geklingelt also es ist quasi so eine Annäherung auf Raten wo du daneben immer wieder in höhere clearance Bereiche,
übernommen wird vom Pentagon da befand sich wohl Google schon auf dem ganz guten Weg.
Leider haben dann die Mitarbeiter ihr etwas neues herausgefunden was neues entdeckt,
ihr müsst ihr Gewissen und diese unglaubliche Entdeckung hat dazu geführt dass einerseits viele Mitarbeiter dann zu einer internen Petition aufgerufen haben.
Musial Google dazu aufgefordert haben diese ganzen militärischen Engagement im Bereich e1.ru stampfen und viele haben auch einfach gekündigt,
SK Polen richtig signifikante Entlassungswelle also Kündigungswelle kein Entlassungswelle.
Dir so sehr gezogen hat das Google hier aus diesem Projekt aussteigt.
Ja finde ich ganz interessant also sie werden diesen Vertrag nicht verlängern im Rahmen von diesem project Maven ob das bedeutet dass Julian gar keiner Front mehr in unserer Form militärisch zusammenarbeiten will ich habe da so meine Zweifel,
ist aber ein schönes Beispiel dafür wie das persönliche Engagement von Leuten hier auch Unternehmen so ein bisschen zur Ordnung rufen kann.
Ja
Amazon hat doch auch ähnliche Situation gehabt ne also bei bei google war es project Maven wo sie für das wo sie also.
Ki in Drohnen bauen wollten und Amazon hatte dann noch irgendwie dieses Rekognition was sie doch auch irgendwo bei bei Videoüberwachungen einbringen wollte.
Also kein Zweifel dass der Amazon ins Haus Fall sogar noch näher dran ist sie haben ja auch schon Datacenter für CIA zra im Betrieb also ich habe die haben da relativ wenig Berührung Probleme.
Ja Amazon hat diese Gesichtserkennungssoftware halt auch an Polizeibehörden verkauft und Socken.
Adresshandel Amazon kennt man ja nun gar nicht zu sehr dafür dass sie da so viel machen.
Aber man muss nichts vor als der größten Software Infrastruktur Unternehmen der Welt das mit der Software haben die schon immer gut hinbekommen.
Den Bereich sind eigentlich alle unterwegs einschließlich Apple also machine learning ist einfach ein großes Ding und wird es noch viel Freude und viel Ärger bereiten.
Amazon hat seine Gesicht erkennungs Technik ÖSV der Royal Wedding damia wieder irgendwie zwei.
Zeige Schwester geheiratet von paar Wochen war doch irgendwie.
Southwest.
Ist das nicht immer das doch immer muss man da nicht wieder feiert das war das Besondere an dieser Royal Hochzeit das herunter also ihr wie nicht standesgemäß geheiratet hatte ne.
Ja es war der Amerikanerin die sogar schwarze also Mutter war glaube ich schwarze Vater ich weiß es nicht genau ich habe das nicht so verfolgt was habe ich mit Britanniens.
Was habe ich damit zu tun.
Hat mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
War im Weg ja man will sich informieren und dann muss erstmal irgendwie an diesen komischen aber du hast Recht das waren keine Geschwister der wurde also ein seltener Moment der Erweiterung des Genpool.
Wurde der in der Inzucht genauer der Inzucht wurde.
Alle vier Generationen muss man da mal bisschen was rein mischen damit man die Kinder noch auseinanderhalten.
Ja aber ist ja auch nicht so schlimm die sowie 13 der Thronfolge oder irgendwie sowas da kann ich viel passieren da kann man das mal machen stell mal vor der gleich der erste hätte das gemacht da wäre aber die Aufregung groß geworden.
Der wahrscheinlichen Unfall passiert der Fall schlechter Witz die aber die haben diese also Amazon hat diese Krabbeln bei.
In den eben dazu ein zum Einsatz gebracht da ein Großbritannien kann man sowas machen ja auch genug Kameras rumhängen kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldung Tim.
Es geht fröhlich weiter um Facebook ja also das hat das nämlich jetzt nur noch das nämlich jetzt nur noch,
nur eine Kurzmeldung mit auf also das jetzt jeden Tag was Neues raus findet bei Facebook noch mit seinen Daten gemacht hat also es gibt ja offenbar immer noch so den Eindruck dass diese Daten die Facebook hat immer nur einfach da sind.
Für uns nee wir haben eine schon 2007,
Levi's integrated Epi gebaut also in einer Zeit als sie noch sehr darum kämpfen mussten den Schritt auf die mobilen Geräte zu schaffen also fahr eine Webseite die Leute nutzen und jetzt auf einmal kam,
diese diese mobilen Geräte daher und Facebook musste.
Rein und da haben sie eben zehn Jahre lang mit über 60 Geräte Herstellern direkt Nutzerdaten von.
Ihren Facebook-Konten den 3. Herstellern zur Verfügung gestellt also sehr.
Auch hier wieder natürlich sehr einleuchtend da kommen also diese Gerätehersteller und sagen ja okay wir wissen nicht wie diese Gerät hier genutzt werden und so ne und was das für Menschen sind wir wollen auch Marktforschung betreiben wer kauft denn hier unsere Dinger und so untersagte Facebook so dumm ist doch gar kein Problem und dann können wir auch zusammen arbeiten,
und dann bekommt ihr über uns über die device integrated EPA eben.
Bessere Einsichten in eure Kunden und wir umgekehrt natürlich auch in der Konsumverhalten und so weiter.
Also da schon 2007.
Eine Datenaustausch und das hat natürlich in den USA dann zu Unmut geführt wo sie dir die Anhörung ja hatten.
Und sagte auch na da scheint er aber doch gelogen zu haben hier ob die Nutzer die volle Kontrolle haben wer wer ihre Daten von Facebook sieht wenn es da über ein Jahrzehnt so eine,
Kooperation gibt mit dem Gerätehersteller in unserer das wird also noch mal einige Diskussionen nach sich ziehen.
Interesse also es ist dass das wird auch so ein bisschen einen Skandal zu Trump and scheint sich langsam.
Als als allgemeine Optionen heraus zu kristallisieren also früher.
Damit jetzt bitte den Skandal zu trampen.
Ja also du übertriffst einfach deine eigenen skaardal noch mal ja dass ich bei mir haben sich zuerst gehört.
Achso ist Volljurist habe jetzt überlegt was das mit Donald Trump zu tun haben könnte.
Nee es hat auch was mit Donald Trump zu tun weil der der der hat ihren Skandal anbacken und denkt sich was auf ich habe eine Idee wie ich den loswerde ich brauche einfach zeitnah einen größeren.
Ja und das ist halt so oder oder also.
Einfach irgendwas schlimmes sagen.
Ihr was schönes sagen oder irgendjemanden beleidigen ne aber früher nannte man das ja Salami Taktik.
Ich glaube das ist inzwischen halt wir träumten das einfach und das scheint ja bei Snowden auch funktioniert zu haben.
Zu großen Teilen nein das ist der durch diese Veröffentlichung.
Nach und nach irgendwann die Leute gar nicht mehr gelesen haben so wie ich jetzt bei den Facebook wer hatte noch Zugriff auf Facebook da an das ungefähr so wer hatte noch ein kostenloses CeBIT Ticket ja.
Kostenlose cebitec.
Ja ich habe auch noch gar ich habe auch noch 50% Gutschein küss die Hälfte zurück von nichts.
Flechtet man so gewundert auf CeBIT Mai.
Ich war bei der CD von Bayern na du was bei dir noch länger her Alter.
Pompa Jahren war ich auch mal da und würd mich mal interessieren wie jetzt ihr neues Konzept so aussieht auf jeden Fall auch nicht zusammengeschrumpft und machen ja jetzt so auf south by Southwest.
Ja und haben dann ihr auch noch geil lassen als lassen share-Online Jedi Kino da halten.
Das 1. sagt so also ich meine er hat ja durchaus ganz ganz harter durchaus auch vertretbare Ansichten aber der I.
Dem Fall hatte er gerade vertretbare Ansichten der sonst sage ich dir für bisschen schwierig aber.
Ffh.de.
Forderung nach einer nicht werbefinanzierten Internet Infrastruktur gehe ich mal mit.
Ja gehe ich mit aber das ist halt auch irgendwie so da kommen alle irgendwie an und dann kaufen kaufen kaufen CeBIT und Markt und Geld und und dann kommt er dann so dass alles scheiße hier.
Ja aber dass ich meine das könnte der CeBIT tatsächlich dazu führen dass sie wieder der relevant bekommt.
Ja also ich ich.
Wenn sogar wieder dieses darüber reden.
Ich wünsche es ihnen ja auch aber ich stell mir halte ich meine der draußen wird gerade irgendwie geredet über na du hast dann hier petertil der irgendwie dann sagt so ja hier mit diesem mit dieser dsgvo,
Europa ab das ist das ist Grab dass es gab und dann kommt ihr CeBIT und sagt ihm wie so ein letztes Mal und der Herr lang jede Nacht,
es ist schon so ein bisschen ich stell mir gerade vor wie die Amerikaner.
Bestimme gerade vor du bist das nächste ja der Kibbuz zwinker.
The CW.
Eröffnet die CeBIT.
Ja da will ich sage ihr könnt jetzt alle wieder ausgegeben.
Ihr seid alle scheiße jetzt riecht nach Lulu.
Freilich also.
Kriechwacholder 11 blöde ist security.
Sieht ihr überhaupt aus also ich finde es sei ihnen zu wünschen.
Dass diese Zeit der Veranstaltung und der Hannover Messe zu wünschen dass sie da ein neues Profil schaffen und es ihnen auch gelingt das mit Leben zu füllen so ich.
Wünsche mir das und hoffe dass dass dass es klappt insofern kein Sport der CeBIT.
Ich war so witzig also Facebook-Daten hat mir jetzt glaube ich auch CeBIT haben als auch komm mal wieder zu traurigen Themen.
Das war ja klar dass jetzt diese Polizeigesetz Nummer um sich greift und werden aber schon gesagt ne also Terror horse sagte sowie das in in Bayern gelaufen ist heute eigentlich überall laufen ist ja sowieso Bayern ist ja,
ein ein einziges Vorbild für ganz Deutschland Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Sagt ach ja cool das könnten wir eigentlich auch noch vor der Sommerpause ein neues Polizeigesetz rausdrücken und da könnten wir am besten noch so eine.
Elektronische Fußfessel WhatsApp Überwachung also Staatstrojaner.
Und irgendwie Polizeigewahrsam auf einen Monat ausweiten das können wir noch kurz vor der Sommerpause hinkriegen lass uns das mal machen insbesondere sein wie er sie wollen hier am auch den Begriff der drohenden Gefahr.
Übernommen sie wollen Taser als neue Waffe haben Nase Taser sind diese Elektroschocker die in den in den USA sehr inflationär verwendet werden.
Das wird dich dass es oder Seuche.
Das ist also das klingt in PA das ist so wie Pfefferspray ne dass sie soll da sagen sie ja auch sie alle das ist doch super.
Nicht letal.
Nicht letal du überlebst.
Ja aber deswegen wird es dann auch permanent angewöhnt ja was willst du denn bisher nicht gestorben irgendwie mir egal wenn hier irgendwie schreist und Grad war es und.
Helsana am laufenden Band irgendwelche.
10 Jahre später von den will den langfristigen Folgen davon verreckt,
lass das ist halt das Problem also gewisser Hinsicht ist zu diese über Bewaffnung eines Polizisten im Sinne von du hast da war gesicherter aber im Prinzip im hochgradig gefährliche Waffe für den Notfall dann übersetze halt auch,
paar Mal.
Wann dieser Notfall eintritt aber durch so eine permanente klein Aufrüstung hat das ja auch schon in der Ausrüstung Schlagstock GZFA Spray insoweit das führt eben einfach zu seiner permanenten Gewaltanwendung die vielleicht dann nicht als,
böse wahrgenommen wird aber natürlich schlimm ankommt.
Jetzt bitte kurz vor einer Kurzmeldungen Gebühr Tragen von wir dann noch mal kurz länger drüber reden weil was wir in Deutschland natürlich haben.
Es denkt er wird ja manchmal unterstellt wir sein irgendwie grundsätzlich gegen die Polizei oder so oder es gibt,
in Deutschland ein paar Entscheidung die echt sehr klug waren was du gerade sagst dass im Polizisten diese Waffe,
bei sich tragen die sie im Notfall benutzen können und wir haben in Deutschland irgendwie sowas wie alle ich glaube wir haben so 11 Uhr Schusswaffeneinsatz im Schnitt im Jahr.
Sind jetzt ein bisschen mehr geworden lädst.
Ja oder in Richtung 20 oder so ne in den USA kommt mit 20 Schüssen ein Polizist nicht durch den Arbeitstag ne würde sowie die haben irgendwie sowas wie 3 oder 5000.
Tote durch Polizei Waffeneinsatz das sind nur die diese umbringen und das ist in Deutschland schon.
Wir haben eine gute polizeikultur.
Und wir wollen diese in diese Route polizeikultur in diesem Land auch pflegen und bewahren so natürlich gibt's irgendwie diese.
Schwarze Schafe Situationen nahim was weiß ich Waffeneinsatz bei und Gegendemonstrationen wir haben Wasserwerfer Einsätze hier nennen,
unvergessen Stuttgart 21 wo sie im alten Mann das Augenlicht genommen haben mit ihrem mit ihrem blöden Wasserwerfer wir haben,
die Diskussion um Polizeigewalt beim G20 die jetzt natürlich auch noch lange nicht vorbei ist die wir ja hier auch behandelt haben aber wir haben auch eine vergleichsweise,
schöne Situation im Vergleich zu der Willkür der du in vielen anderen Ländern ausgesetzt ist weil du da eben nicht so eine,
doch irgendwie noch greifenden Ehrenkodex der Polizei hast okay jetzt Taser geile Sache so dann werden die denn dann besserte die nächsten bei jeder Gelegenheit irgendwie zu Boden geschockt.
Mit diesen Elektroschockern.
Die Schmerzen erzeugen die nicht ohne sind das ist nicht so mal eben kurz in Steckdose fassen soll das ist er so lange in die Steckdose fassen.
Das ist das ist gefährlich für Herz für Nerven das ist nicht lustig.
Da sind auch viele schon gestorben also dieses Argument das sei nicht letal ja das sind nicht unmittelbar letal aber dass dass das kann sehr wohl letale Folgen haben insbesondere wenn sie halt übermäßig zum Einsatz kommen und das kann er dann eben auch passieren,
Portier Motorräder dich jetzt mal hier richtig durch.
Schleierfahndung mit anhalte und Sichtkontrollen wollen sie haben also mit anderen Worten racial Profiling ne weiß ja wer verdächtig aussieht heutzutage an öffentlichen Orten die Videoüberwachung ausweiten wie schon sagte Staatstrojaner,
um Kommunikation mit zu lesen also ihr die Stadt t-online.de.
PKU Quellen-TKÜ Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung Online-Durchsuchung.
Anordnung von aufenthaltsbeschränkung und Kontakt verboten als präventiv polizeiliche Maßnahme.
Überwachung durch Fußfessel und,
die Verlängerung der Ingewahrsamnahme z.b. zur Identitätsfeststellung auf 7 Tage und bei terroristischer Gefahr auf einen Monat das ist auch etwas was du kannst wenn du,
dich auch leider mal selber lernen musste dich nicht ausweisen zu können ist nicht unbedingt eine kluge Idee.
Weil die Polizei daneben sagt ok dann wir werden jetzt dich halt in Gewahrsam nehmen bis wir dann Identität festgestellt haben da hast du die ruckzuck in der Bude also ehrlich gesagt empfiehlt sich das und Personalausweis dabei zu haben für alle die das.
Noch nicht gelernt haben hier daneben Feststellung festhalten 7 Tage bei terroristischer Gefahr auf einen Monat.
So das ist also das nicht zumindest dann das ein Polizeigesetz im Hauruckverfahren angekündigt hat es gibt ein Bündnis dagegen www.no Polizeigesetz nrw.de wo die Kritik noch mal zusammen.
Gefasst wurde wo eine Reihe an Unterzeichnern sich eben gegen dieses Polizeigesetz Wänden wo Aktionen.
Gesammelt werden wo zu einer Demonstration am 7. Juli aufgerufen wird ja da könnt ihr euch also auch schon mal drauf einrichten dass wenn ihr in Nordrhein-Westfalen,
wohnt oder zu diesem Zeitpunkt Uhrzeit am Samstag den 7.7 in Düsseldorf Demonstration.
Gegen das bezahl gesetzt Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Ja wie schön ist doch ist in einem CDU FDP regierten anzuheben ne das gibt einfach schon mal korrekte neue Polizeigesetze.
Nur dumm dass irgendwie die gesehen dass die Finanzverwaltung die in NRW so wunderbar effizient gegen Korruption und Steuerbetrug an gekämpft hat daher als erstes Mal zusammen gestrichen wurde tolles Land dass er da habt irgendwie.
Also könnte auch mal wieder aufräumen meine Herrn ergibt eigentlich irgendeinen der nicht komplett frei dreht derzeit ist wirklich alles echt unfassbar es für dich schwierig.
Meine Fresse Tip an ankommende Politiker man kann sich auch.
Romont Ordens und Verdienste schaffen indem man vielleicht mal wieder für was Gutes ist so muss nicht immer nur der härteste Hund sein.
Veinland irgendwie mit Besonnenheit also ich bin inzwischen entwickle ich so ganz ganz komische,
zarte Gefühle inwiefern für Angela Merkel oder oder oder Barack Obama aber du merkst okay die haben sich wenigstens was dabei gedacht so die haben ihr wenigstens in der Sekunde nachgedacht so die haben irgendwie die sind sich.
Des Ausmaßes der Situation bewusst und versuchen.
Das Richtige zu tun ja werden wir jetzt irgendwie in letzter Zeit nur noch irgendwelche.
Vollhonks am Starter.
Die hast du jetzt gerade zarte Gefühle für Angela Merkel als Sendungstitel Note.
IV geile Tittel den ich ja aufgeschrieben habe.
Bis Willich.
Aber drüber abgestellt.
Aber wenn du so wenn du dir anschaust was.
Es geht mir ganz schnell.
Nee aber wenn du dir an wenn du dir wenn du die diese bräsige knife Bela anschaust dann anguckst wie also was diese CDU was die für ein Personal hat das ja auch einfach so auch.
Und dann hast du diese Bild Zeitungs Hetze im Land ja wäre mir jetzt gar nicht Wärme sehr einfach ignoriert dass wir jetzt hier diesen.
Diesen Mordfall hatten der gerade wieder die die Ausländerhetze in diesem Land befeuert.
Es ist zusehends einfach ähm also das ist einfach das verletzt einfach mein ästhetisches Empfinden in diesem Land was ich hier jeden Tag sehe nicht nur diesen Land auch.
Genau ihr mächtigen gesagt wie total oder ästhetisch.
Ja die Verletzten mein ästhetisches Empfinden da freue ich mich doch mit dass wir eine Bundesjustizministerin mit dem schönen Namen Bali haben dieser Name ist also sorry das heißt halt.
Ja das ist das erinnert mich an eine Brauerei in Berlin.
Wirklich.
Ja
Wie kommst Du darauf und.
Ja und der ist jetzt nicht so der Name der bei mir Siri Seriosität aus.
Strahlt aber sie hat sich jetzt ein Thema gesucht wo man denkt er wenigstens mal etwas muss ich also sagt.
Sie hätte gerne dass diese messenger.
Die WhatsApp per Gesetz Zusammenarbeit zur Zusammenarbeit gezogen werden also sie möchte Interoperabilität erzwingen.
Fluss zwischen den unterschiedlichen messenger Anbietern was ganz interessant ist weil der Hintergrund ist ja hier.
Der der immer wiederkehrende das immer wieder keine Problem der föderalisieren Systeme und der zentralisierten Systeme Beispiel für einen föderalisieren System noch ist E-Mail ja man kann.
Jeder jede die möchte kann sich entscheiden ein E-Mail-Server aufzusetzen und zu betreiben es ist bisschen schmerzhaft aber es geht.
Und dann ist dieser E-Mail Server interoperabel mit allen anderen E-Mail Servern und man kann sich dann E-Mails schicken kann auch einen Jabber Server aufsetzen oder was kann man noch aufsetzen natürlich hier Mastodon.
Und identica und solche Scherze kannst du alles machen und kannst dann deinen eigenen Server betreiben der dann mit den anderen interoperabel ist alternativ sagst du nervös sind dann Geschäftsmodell wenn die anderen das auch machen können.
Ich mache 11 zentrale Infrastruktur und.
Wie nenne ich Whatsapp und alles was darüber läuft geht durch meinen Server und die Daten dabei anfallen gehen an Facebook.
Und das ist also das zentralisierte Geschäftsmodell was eben darauf was einerseits die Hürde hat anfangs nicht,
interoperabel zu sein wenn es dann aber die kritische Masse überschritten hat im Prinzip quasi eine Monopol Position hat,
von der.
Sie so schnell nicht mehr weggestoßen werden können und da sagt dann jetzt die Justizministerin ja nee wir wollen Aldi eigentlich also da WhatsApp sagen wenn mein sportsvan bei Whatsapp eine aufsteigt und sagt.
Aufsteht und sagte eben Meeting Elbe könnten interoperabel werden zu was weiß ich zu threema und un cygne wär doch voll geil dann.
Könnte man den Messenger seiner Wahl benutzen dann würden die halt einmal kurz lachen.
Und wenn er dann sagt wieso dann würden sie halt sagen sie den halt wahrscheinlich zum Arzt schicken ne also das kommt für diese und Unternehmen überhaupt nicht infrage deswegen.
Aus guten und aus schlechten wird muss man das sagen.
Genau und die schlechten Gründe habe ich glaube ich so ein bisschen gewürdigt dass es als Geschäftsmodelle sind sag mal die guten Gründe weil es gibt auch gute Gründe müsste man halt glaube ich auch tatsächlich wenigstens mal würdigen.
Naja also ich meine wenn du eine gut funktionierende Software machen wir's er muss natürlich da einerseits Qualität reinstecken das heißt du musst irgendwie sicherstellen dass das irgendwie auch alles ordentlich funktioniert das Dakine,
auch keine generellen grundsätzlichen Fehler eingebaut hast erzählt und wenn du alles unter Kontrolle hast und hast natürlich auch die Möglichkeit genau diese Qualitätslevel auch zu erreichen oder irgendwie auch besser zu werden und du kannst eben auch schnell an geänderte Bedingungen reagieren ne also wenn sich Netze auf einmal anders verhalten Standard anders gesetzt werden,
dass ich hier Verschlüsselung Ports alles was im Internet in irgendeiner Form Rolle spielen kann das ist ja ein Moving Target und Software muss einfach permanent maintained werden um überhaupt,
den versprochenen Qualitätslevel zu halten geschweige denn Möglichkeiten zu haben besser zu werden wenn du jetzt,
sagst na ja wir müssen aber gerne dass ihr jetzt hier interoperabel Seite ist das ja ein hehres Ziel würde aber eben auch bedeuten dass man erstmal.
Und ein Standard quasi implementieren müsste ja oder also je nachdem wie so ein Gesetz zur gefastet man könnte ja auch sagen wenn du so und so viel Marktanteil hast dann musst du irgendwie auch alle anderen reinlassen so,
wie willst du denn dann deine Sicherheit noch garantieren wenn die Leute da so ziemlich mit anderen Systemen kommunizieren können also normal so wie bei SMS da weiß ja auch nicht welches,
Geräte hinter einer Telefonnummer steht da dass der quasi der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner der Messenger und an der Stelle gibt es im übrigen auch schon eine hinter Operabilität.
Du hast dich die Interoperabilität mit den Programmen aber du hast die Interoperabilität,
ja mit den Teilnehmern ja also in der Regel kann ja jeder der müssen Mobiltelefon hat ist darüber erreichbar natürlich kannst du mit Messenger nach ohne Telefon arbeiten jetzt hätte also wird auch schwierig aber es gibt in gewisser Hinsicht diesen kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner,
auch aber was heißt der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner der heißt halt naja dann ist halt total unverschlüsselt jeder Telekommunikationsanbieter,
kann das sozusagen einfach mitlesen und tut es dann Zeit Fall auch das ganze geht durch das extrem schlecht gemachte und schlecht gesicherte,
Telekommunikationsnetz auf ss7 Basis na so wie es das Internet gibt und die ganzen IP-basierten sachen gibt's net Telekommunikations Welt zwischen diesem Mobilfunk und Festnetz Anbieter,
weil sie das digitale ss7 System hat mir glaube ich ja auch irgendwie am Rande öfter schon mal das Thema dass das da sozusagen ganz schlimm aussieht mit der Security da könnte ich Leute also problemlos,
derselben Ebene wie ganze Länder oder einblenden der Zentrale ist problematisch beim 1.mal nur bei Internet bleibt und darauf läuft er langfristig hinaus.
Bus jetzt quasi so eine unseren Unternehmen wie Apple zwingen somit iMessage stand eben auch facebook-messenger zu erreichen und umgekehrt ne,
und im.
Wer richtet sich denn jetzt hier nach Westen Standard wer gibt denn jetzt hier eigentlich vor wie eine Implementierung zu seiner wer stellt die sicher.
Wer korrigiert wenn sich rausstellt dass die aber total unsicher ist und daneben auf einmal diese Interoperabilität Schnittstelle das eigentliche Einfallstor für Hackerangriffe ist so,
kannst du dir dann jederzeit runterfahren oder nicht was ja wirst du dann dafür verurteilt dass du keine Interoperabilität hast ja also das da ist so ein Rattenschwanz an Problemen dran wo ich glaube wo es würdigten massiv dran,
Zeitansatz könnt jetzt noch.
Es es gibt da ein es gibt da einen entscheiden oder einen fand ich sehr sehr gewichtigen Blogpost von Moxie marlinspike den er 2016 formuliert hat da ging es.
Also maximal in Spike der Gründervater von Signal ja also er hat.
Im Prinzip Signal erst gestartet das Unternehmen Signal hat die das Protokoll entwickelt ja das ja auch sehr viel Lob.
Und von vielen Leuten bekommt und er sagt er reflektiert in diesem Haus darüber ob man Signal.
Infiltriert machen könnte also als ba7 jeder betraten zeugnisserver wieder weh und dann sagt er.
Kids and highly possible to build a federated Signal protocol based messenger but I no longer believe that is possible to build a competitive federated messenger Addon und er sah er.
Sagt halt mit diesen mit einem frisierten System bist du in der Zeit gefangen und er sagt für dich da ein sehr schönes Beispiel sagt er,
ich finde das total toll dass ich einen eigenen E-Mail Server betreiben kann aber die Tatsache dass ich es kann.
Ist auch der Grund dafür dass meine E-Mail nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt ist und es im Zweifelsfall auch nie sein wird weil wenn man einmal so eine Interoperabilität geschaffen hat man in dieser.
Auf ewig gefangen bleibt.
Ebay ist immer noch so auf dem Stand der 80er.
Du könntest natürlich irgendwie also.
Beispiel sagen ok die Interoperabilität Schnittstelle ist stattdessen als SMS versenden ja und dann könntest du sagen naja okay und jetzt gehen jetzt ziehen wir das langsam an jetzt gibt's auch noch stattdessen,
über euch mal die von Signal verwendete Verschlüsselung versenden,
oder über die von threema verwendete Verschlüsselung versenden und irgendwie gucken dass der ganze Mist auch noch mit Whatsapp funktioniert und der Fähre aber am Ende ein sehr heilloses Durcheinander das,
wahrscheinlich leider.
Nicht funktionieren würde und keiner hätte Lust Dich auf die auf die anderen einzulassen also wie ist es da das schöne an Standards ist es gibt so viele die man von dem man sich einen aussuchen könnte man würde einfach wahrscheinlich einen neuen schreiben.
Und sagen okay das ist jetzt der Basis Standard für Messenger und dann stellt sich die Frage ok du tust deinen Messenger der Audio Nachrichten.
Versenden kann was machen wir mit.
Wenn jetzt an jemanden sendest der keine Audio Nachrichten empfangen kannst du bitte ein Bild oder ein Video schicken oder du möchtest jetzt telefonieren oder dass der Messenger von der anderen Person unterstützt das aber nicht du könntest das alles abbilden.
Man könnte dann auch Protokollversion machen wo man sagt ok du sprichst nicht Interop Messenger Version 3.11 tja.
Pech du müsstest aber dann auch jedes Mal zwischen den Messenger das wieder aushandeln äh hallo ich bin ein messager vom Typ.
Vom Typ Interoperabilität XP.
Oder du müsstest das Netz halt auch so einer.
Basis aufbauen dass du sagst jeder der hier daran teilnehmen muss garantieren innerhalb einer bestimmten Zeit ein Upgrade auf eine neue Version vorgenommen zu haben,
ja dass du sagst ok bei jedem Protokoll Wechsel gibt's genau drei Monate Zeit wie lange das noch funktioniert und dann muss es weitergehen.
Aber wer definiert dieses Protokoll am Ende definieren scroogle und Facebook weil sie die Zeit dafür haben.
Ja weiß nicht was ich meine wenn jetzt mit sowas offenem kommst dann wird sich glaube ich Google und Facebook erstmal überhaupt nicht dran beteiligen weil sie daran auch gar kein Interesse haben.
Mein Mann hat bei Jabba auch schon gesehen das ist ja ist ja genau dasselbe Problem die Kunden sich dann auch irgendwann nicht mehr weiterentwickeln und wurden dann auch von den Messenger technisch abgehängter weil sie halt einfach.
Da auf http gesetzt haben und auf andere Sachen und das funktionierte einfach besser an kann es viele technische Argumente bringen der Wunsch nach Interoperabilität ja der ist an sich ganz okay so.
Ich finde den sehr sehr wichtig.
Ich finde ihn auch eigentlich ganz wichtig die Frage ist nur auf welchem Weg könnte man die erreichen und was glaube ich,
wirklich unrealistisch ist ist sozusagen so einen davon zu träumen so ein wir machen jetzt mal ein universelles Protokoll weil jeder der sich in dem Moment an dieses Protokoll reinhängt.
Verunmöglicht eine Verbesserung dann ist das sozusagen für die nächsten 20 Jahre festgeschrieben und damit an ich auch schon tot weil,
Messenger entwickeln sich weiter wenn man sich mal anschaut wie WhatsApp und so weiter gestartet sind,
ohne Verschlüsselung ICH und mit wie viel viel weniger Features na die ist alle nur groß geworden weil sie ein oder zwei gute Ideen hatten ne WhatsApp hat gewonnen weil sie irgendwie die.
Partnerwahl quasi über Telefonnummer gemacht haben und weil sie einfach stabil funktioniert haben,
so die konnten schnell wachsen und das war das einzige was WhatsApp nach oben befördert hat da war von den ganzen anderen Features noch nicht die Rede und die konnten sich auch erlauben die Verschlüsselung irgendwie später mal oben drauf zu legen und dann,
ringsum wir trotzdem noch weiter du musst musst dein Protokoll permanent ändern können und nur nur dann bis Lage in dieser Landschaft noch mitzuhalten.
Und deswegen muss man sich vielleicht eher Gedanken darüber machen wie man eben explizit Leuten sozusagen Nachrichten schicken kann über so Interoperabilität Server die,
ihrerseits sich bemühen müssen mit alldem kompatibel zu sein so oder,
ja das bisschen schon dass ich die Verpflichtung der Unternehmen sein ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel drüber nachgedacht wie man das tatsächlich hinbekommen könnte ist auf jeden Fall total schwierig.
Es ist schwierig aber es wäre gleichzeitig tatsächlich eine.
Wettbewerbsrechtlich sinnvolle Maßnahme und es ist natürlich auch gehört zu den,
Bestrebungen des Chaos Computer Clubs Dezentralität zu fördern insofern stehe ich schon hinter dieser dieser Idee der guten Frau Bali und fände das natürlich sehr toll,
denke nur dass das eben leider nicht mit den absoluten Segnungen einhergeht,
gehen würde Anna wir haben wunderschöne,
wir haben ja auch gute Beispiele für föderierte für föderierte Systeme und es ist nicht so als wären die.
Während die tot oder so ja wie gesagt dieses Mastodon sehe ich ganz klar wachsen.
Aber eben auch natürlich nicht so dass es jetzt in naher Zukunft Facebook verdrängt wird und das wäre.
Da wird irgendeine Form von Intervention notwendig sein,
um da diese Macht zu brechen und unter Umständen wäre es eben die Verpflichtung auf irgendeine Basis Schnittstelle die dann natürlich nicht den vollen Funktionsumfang abbildet und die messenger würden dann konkurrieren um Features die die anderen nicht haben.
Um sich wieder von dem Basis.
Protokoll irgendwie zu verabschieden und wieder Alleinstellungsmerkmale zu haben aber ich fände es natürlich super wenn ich aus dem Messenger meiner war auch in andere Messenger schreiben müsste könnte.
Da müsste ich nämlich mehr dann könnte ich ruhigen Gewissens mit diesem diesem blöden WhatsApp mich nicht auseinandersetzen müssen,
nah und gut wirst du trotzdem dass ich Menschen die auf die über diese Weise kommunizieren können.
Das daneben auch irgendwie mit mir tun können also dass das.
Das Ziel ist ein hehres und es wäre schön diese Dezentralität zu fördern und es wäre wahrscheinlich geht es nicht anders als in dem man sie fordert.
Ja ich meine hier gibt's hatte ich dann staatlicherseits dass ich auch wieder viele verpasste Chancen es gibt ja z.b. den ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was der offizielle Name ist.
Good jokes.
Es gibt sozusagen ein von den Telcos jetzt geputzten Nachfolger der SMS ja wo sie dann quasi auch,
bisschen mit dem Feature-Set nachziehen bei Google google hat dafür eine App rausgebracht die sind ja am Android untergebracht haben da ist das irgendwie Chat eigentlich Standard hat jetzt anders mir gerade entfallen.
Ja genau rcswitch irgendwas chat.
Service RWA wie keine Ahnung so ein Quatsch auf jeden Fall ist dann halt auch wieder unverschlüsselt und so und fragt man sich halt auch wirklich,
so okay das ist jetzt irgendwie nah 20 Jahren Mobilfunk alles was er um die auf den Tisch legen könnt und irgendwie mit messenger zu konkurrieren durch will irgendwie euch euch nicht,
dazu durchringen könnte mal die Telcos aller Länder und wir auf dem Verschlüsselungsstandards zusammenzubringen ja kann ich gut verstehen ne weil dann ist es steht da Dubai und sagt,
mich machen wir nicht weil wir wollen ja mal schön unsere Leute weiter überwachen während ihren Scheiß tun uns irgendwie auch noch mit weiteren Verschlüsselungsstandard einzutreten immer erst wieder knacken müssen,
so geht's halt auch nicht voran so und wenn man solche Angebote staatlicherseits und in der internationalen Gesellschaft und ich machen kann dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern dass Sie Messenger entfleuchen gewisser Hinsicht das ist halt so ein bisschen Fluch und Segen zugleich wir haben mit dem Messenger an.
Einerseits halt wieder Sohn.
Neue proprietäre fallen bekommen wenn den man dann auch fleißig reinpasst.
Andererseits hat sich aber auch die Sicherheit der Kommunikation und die Flexibilität der Kommunikation durch dieses Thema so.
Unfassbar positiv verändert man sagen kann na ja gut vielleicht ist halt auch diese Ballons dann auch ein Fortschritt in sich.
Nur schwierig zu beantworten aber.
Dafür und darüber gut Gedanken zu führen gibt's ja noch euch.
David Filme die Sendung auch langsam zu Ende mit dem Wunsch nach Feedback nicht dass wir keins bekommen würden,
bekommen wir die Kommentarspalten sind in der Regel gut gefüllt aber gerade solche Gedanken dürfte gerne mal aufgreifen hat er hierzu zwei drei Sachen wo wir uns auch nicht so ganz sicher sind wie man den hier am besten argumentiert und wohin die Reise gehen soll vielleicht ist das ja auch mal ein Thema,
für euch aber da ihr bringt euch gerne ein das finde gut und macht es auch weiter so wir machst du noch zu danken.
Ich würde das Feedback ne gerne auch wieder Telefon Teams vertritt schon wieder die Augen.
Funktioniert nicht.
Da ist ich bin überrascht alles funktioniert schon manchmal so wir kriegen ja auch tatsächlich regelmäßig Anrufe ist halt nicht immer so dass ich sag okay den den nimmt man jetzt auch in die Sendung mit ein aber es hat,
sim auch als direkt ein Feedback Kanal zu uns ein bisschen.
Reiz sich das anzuhören für mich zu esse ich freue mich dann immer wenn eine Nachricht kommt also 030 120 88.
388 wenn ihr auf unseren Logbuch Netzpolitik Anrufbeantworter sprechen.
Okay wenn du unbedingt möchtest,
ich wollte noch mal an danke losschicken an Jan Heiko die nämlich im wie mir teilweise zu einem Teil erst im Rahmen von LMP 356 gewahr wurde irgendwie diese winterlichen großartigen lnp Einhorn Standarte Aufklebern stehen,
Wünsche auch lieber den Entwürfen Entschuldigung wir haben da jetzt auch mal Aufkleber draus gemacht wenn ihr uns treffen irgendwo werden vielleicht immer welche dabei.
Und überlegen wir uns mal wie wir die noch weiter und das Volk bringen können wenn ihr auf jeden Fall mal auf der anderen Veranstaltungen streuen.
Malte weil es noch noch keinen Versand oder so auf das wäre es jetzt noch ein bisschen zu viel.
Schicken Sie eine frankierten Rückumschlag.
Schicken Sie eine frankierte Rückkehr Sam s-lite überlegen uns das gerade so ein bisschen über diesen ganzen Bereich ein bisschen aufbauen können aber an dieser Stelle ist erstmal wichtig danke zu sagen neues gemacht du hast noch zwei.
Max und Markus gilt mein Dank.
Gut dann war es das.
Für heute und für diese Woche und da war.
Genau und dann aber heute ist nicht alle Tage.
Wir kommen wieder keine Frage Talkshow.
Keine Frage Tschüß.